>> HE DID A VERY GOOD JOB WHEN
HE WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE HOPE HE HAS A WONDERFUL
CAREER.
HOPEFULLY HE WILL HAVE A GREAT
CAREER I’VE HAD OF HIM.
HE SAYS HE’S INNOCENT.
AND I THINK YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT.
>> Chris: PRESIDENT TRUMP
EXPRESSING SURPRISE AND SOME OF
THE DELAY FOR FORMER ADVISOR ROB
PORTER IN THE DOMESTIC ABUSE
SCANDAL.
BUT HE DID NOT MENTION PORTER’S
TWO EX-WIVES WHO MADE THE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST HIM.
LET’S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
MATT SCHLAPP WITH "THE HILL,"
KAREN TUMULTY OF
"THE WASHINGTON POST," AND TOM
ROGAN FROM THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER" ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT’S COMMENTS ABOUT ROB
PORTER, HELPED TAMP DOWN THE
CONTROVERSY OR FURTHER INFLAME
THEM?
>> I THINK THEY FURTHER INFLAME
THEM.
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IS
SOMEBODY WHO’S BEEN CREDIBLY
ACCUSED OF A CRIME.
AND IT IS HARD TO THINK OF ANY
OTHER CRIME WHERE YOU WOULD HAVE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SITTING THERE AND
SAYING, BASICALLY, HE DID A
GOOD JOB WHILE HE WAS HERE.
>> HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN IT?
>> I THINK THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
VERY MUCH DRIVEN BY LOYALTY OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN LOYAL TO
HIM.
I THINK IN THIS CASE, HE HAS
LOST TRACK OF WHAT THE BIG
PICTURE IS.
>> Chris: LET ME ASK YOU.
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND HIS WANTING
TO REACH OUT AND SAY I
APPRECIATE ROB PORTER’S SERVICE.
BUT ISN’T IT REMARKABLY
TONE-DEAF NOT TO EVEN MENTION
WHEN HE’S TALKING ABOUT SOME OF
THESE ALSO TO THE TWO EX-WIVES?
>> THAT’S THE BALANCE HERE.
WHEN THESE FBI REPORTS COME IN
ON A WHITE HOUSE STAFF, THERE
ARE ROB REPORTS.
PEOPLE SAY A DOME I CAN SAY
AWFULLY GOOD THINGS OR PEOPLE
CAN SAY NASTY THINGS.
THE DIFFERENCE IS HERE YOU HAVE
TWO EX-WIVES, ONE OF THEM WHO I
SAW TODAY ON TELEVISION TELLING
THEIR STORY.
IT’S JARRING.
I KNOW ROB PORTER.
IT’S A SHOCKING THING THAT
SOMEBODY IS SAYING THIS THING
ABOUT HIM.
I THINK IT’S APPROPRIATE TO -- I
THINK GENERAL KELLY DID A
GOOD JOB WITH HIS SECOND
STATEMENT ABOUT ACKNOWLEDGING
THESE ARE VERY SERIOUS CHARGES.
IT’S ALSO SHOCKING TO PEOPLE WHO
WORKED WITH ROB WHO FELT LIKE
THEY KNEW HIM.
BUT SOMETHING LIKE THIS COULD BE
SAID ABOUT HIM.
>> Chris: YOU TALK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT KELLY DID A GOOD JOB
THERE.
THERE’S BEEN LOTS OF CRITICISM
ON KELLY AND I WANT TO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT THAT FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS
REPORTING THAT AT TODAY’S
WHITE HOUSE STAFF MEETING, THE
CHIEF OF STAFF, GENERAL KELLY,
PUT OUT A STORY THAT A LOT OF
THE STAFFERS ARE ON THE PEOPLE
DO NOT BELIEVE THIS IS TRUE,
THAT WHICH IS AS SOON AS HE
LEARNED ABOUT THE ALLEGATIONS
AND THE GREAT ABILITY OF THE
ALLEGATIONS, WITHIN 40 MINUTES,
HE MOVED AGAINST PORTER.
TWO CAMPAIGN AIDES, WHO DURING
THE CAMPAIGN WERE STILL IN FREE
AND WITH THE PRESIDENT WENT
AFTER KELLY TODAY.
>> THE GENERAL IS THERE TO PUT
IN POLICIES AND PROCEDURES.
IN THIS CASE, THOSE DIDN’T WORK.
WE NEED TO FIND OUT WHY.
>> THIS IS AN EMBARRASSMENT FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT’S A SETBACK FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Chris: MATT, HOW MUCH
TROUBLE AS KELLY IN?
>> I THINK THIS IS A DAMAGING
SERIES OF EVENTS.
I THINK HIS FIRST RESPONSE TO
THE CHARGES DID NOT DO WHAT
KAREN SAID, WHICH IS CONNECT TO
THE FACT THAT THESE ARE SERIOUS
CHARGES.
I HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
YOU HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THERE
ARE CERTAIN CHARGES.
I DO THINK IT’S INCORRECT TO SAY
THAT HE KNEW BEFORE THAT TIME HE
SAID TO ME, WHICH WAS SOMETIME
ON TUESDAY.
>> HE SAYS HE’S GOT SOME
INFORMATION FOR HE’S SAYING HE’S
GOT SOME INFORMATION IN
SEPTEMBER.
>> LET ME EXPLAIN THIS REALLY
QUICK TO THE VIEWERS.
SOMEONE WHO’S BEEN ON THESE FBI
BACKGROUND CHECKS, THEY TAKE A
LONG TIME.
SOMETIMES, THEY WILL REPORT BACK
THERE ARE ISSUES.
ONCE AGAIN, IT IS RAW DATA THAT
PEOPLE ARE RAISING AND SOMETIMES
YOU GET PEOPLE DURING THE FDR
PROCESS WHO WILL THEN
IMMEDIATELY CALL SOMEONE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
SOMEBODY ON THE STAFF, WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT’VE HAPPENED
HERE AS WELL.
HOW DID YOU FIGURE OUT, CHRIS,
WHEN YOU ARE THE BOSS, HOW DO
YOU FIGURE OUT WHERE THE TRUTH
IS, WHERE THE TRUTH IS IN?
YOU DO HAVE TO GIVE SOME TIME --
>> Chris: I PROMISE I WILL
BRING YOU IN.
KAREN, I HAVE A FEELING YOU ARE
REACTING TO THIS.
IF HE LEARNS THERE IS
ALLEGATIONS OF DOMESTIC ABUSE,
WHY WOULDN’T HIS HAIR GO ON
FIRE?
WHY WOULDN’T HE SAY TO THE FBI,
IS THERE PROOF?
IS THERE A COURT CASE QUITS
BECAUSE THEIR PHOTOGRAPHS?
THE FBI HAD ALL THE INFORMATION
BY SEPTEMBER.
>> EXACTLY.
AND HIS PRIMARY JOB IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
PROTECTED HERE, THAT THERE IS
NOTHING HAPPENING THAT IS GOING
TO REFLECT BADLY ON THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT IS WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF SHOULD HAVE AS A
TOP CONCERN.
YES, THAT SHOULD’VE BEEN A LOT
MORE AGGRESSIVE FROM THE MINUTE
HE HEARD THE FIRST INKLING OF
THIS TO FINDING OUT WHAT THE
TRUTH IS AND NOT JUST WAITING
FOR THE TRUTH TO COME TO HIM.
>> Chris: TOM, WHEN KELLY
FIRST CAME IN, I THINK IT’S FAIR
TO SAY THAT HE WAS GOING TO BE
THE GROWN-UP.
HE WAS GOING TO BE THE PERSON
WHO IMPOSED ORDER AND DISCIPLINE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
MISSTEPS SINCE HE FIRST CAME.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF
THEM.
I WILL PUT THEM ON THE SCREEN.
HE GOT INTO A FIGHT OVER THE
PRESENCE PHONE CALL WITH A WIDOW
OF A FALLEN SOLDIER.
HE SAID SOME IMMIGRANTS WERE
"TOO LAZY" TO APPLY TO DREAMER
STATUS.
HE INITIALLY, LATER THIS WEEK,
CALLED ROB PORTER A MAN OF TRUE
INTEGRITY AND HONOR.
AND HE TOLD BRET BAIER DURING AN
INTERVIEW ON FOX AFTER TALKING
TO A CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE
THAT CANDIDATE TRUMP DURING THE
CAMPAIGN WAS UNINFORMED ABOUT
IMMIGRATION.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> HE HAS EVOLVED IN THE WAY
HE’S LOOKED AT THINGS.
CAMPAIGNED
CAMPAIGNING AND GOVERNING OUR
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS.
THIS PRESIDENT IS VERY, VERY
FLEXIBLE WITH WHAT IS IN THE
REALM OF THE POSSIBLE.
>> Chris: TOM, WE WERE TOLD
THE PRESIDENT WAS NOT AMUSED BY
THOSE CONFIDENCE.
IS HE ON SHAKY GROUND?
>> I THINK HE IS.
WHEN YOU SEE THE SLIP-UPS, THERE
ARE TWO THINGS GOING ON HERE FOR
THE FIRST ONE, JOHN KELLY COMING
TO THE WHITE HOUSE CAME FROM A
VERY DIFFERENT BACKGROUND.
THE MILITARY STRUCTURE, THE
MARINE CORPS, WHERE LEADERSHIP,
TRUST, LOYALTY ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THINGS.
BUT THE POLITICAL DIMENSION OF
WASHINGTON AND THE PRICE, ARE
NOT KNOWN WITH DEALING.
GOING SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR
QUESTION, CHRIS, THE CALLS FOR
THE PRESIDENT’S REGARD FOR
MILITARY OFFICES, MILITARY
OFFICERS OR DIFFERENTIAL TO HIM,
WHO EXPECT THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF POSITION.
BECAUSE JOHN KELLY, CONSISTENCY
ULTIMATELY YIELDS TO THE
PRESIDENT AND WHO DOES THE
PRESIDENT’S BIDDING AND FORCES
THINGS THROUGH, I THINK HE
STAYS.
>> Chris: THOSE ARE THOSE
INFAMOUS, ANONYMOUS SOURCES WHO
ARE SAYING THAT AT LEAST THE
PRESIDENT IS TALKING ABOUT OTHER
PEOPLE, MICK MULVANEY, TOM
McCARTHY, TOM BARRETT, HIS OLD
FRIEND, AN INVESTOR IN
CALIFORNIA.
YOU DON’T BELIEVE THOSE STORIES?
>> THE PRESIDENT PROBABLY IS.
I THINK HE DOES THIS --
REMEMBER, SIX MONTHS AGO BEFORE
THAT EVENING, WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT SECRETARY OF STATE
REX TILLERSON WAS ON HIS WAY
OUT.
WE’VE HAD IT WITH MANY NAMES.
IN THIS CASE, THE PRESIDENT
SAYING TO JOHN KELLY, I’M A
LITTLE BIT UPSET HERE, TRY AND
IMPROVE.
>> Chris: MATT, DO YOU AGREE
WITH THAT?
YOU THINK STELLY TELL MY KELLY
STAYS?
>> I
THINK ONE MAN KNOWS.
BARACK OBAMA HAD EIGHT CODES
DON’T MAKE CHIEF OF STAFF’S IN
EIGHT YEARS.
I WOULDN’T BE SURPRISED IF WE
WOULD HAVE STAFF COME AND GO.
I THINK JOHN KELLY HAS RIGHTED